A Griebang cho bán mười lâm nghiên tì động trẻ phía ra công chúng,
mạnh giá một trong nghiên đồng trên một trẻ phía,
kiaa mười năm, lại sất thả nổi.
Thưa ra đăng ký từ mười tháng bẩy đến bà mốt tháng bẩy.
Theo đó, nhà đầu tư là các tổ chức,
cá nhân Việt Nam và nước ngoài có thể đăng ký mùa trẻ phíaa à Griebang
từ ngày mười tháng bẩy năm nay nhìn không trọng 20 xấu,
đến ngày 30 x 20 x 20 xấu,
tại chủ sở chính,
và tất cả các điểm rau dịch của A Griebang trên toàn Quốc,
và thông qua đại lý phát hành công ty của bệnh chính khoan A Griebang, A Griebang.
Trẻ phía có mảy giá một trong nghiên đồng trên một trẻ phía,
kiaa mười năm, chả lại định ký mỗi năm một lần.
Lại sất được át dụ thử theo cơ chế thả nổi,
được tính bằng lại sất thảm chiếu cộp biên độ hai phần chăm 1 năm,
trong 5 năm đầu,
và hai phy năm phần chăm 1 năm, trong 5 năm, nằm quý.
Lại sất thảm chiếu được sất định trên cơ sở,
bình quân lại sất tình người tiếp kiệm cá nhân bằng viên đi,
kiaa mười hai tháng, chả lại khối kiệp của bún ngân hàng Quốc sáng tại thời điểm sách định lại sất.
Sau khi kết thúc lợp cho bán,
chá phíau sẽ được năng ký tập chung tại tổng tì lưu ký và vụ trở chính khoan Việt Nam VsDC.
Nhà đồ thưa có thể lưu ký,
mua bán, chuyển nhật, hoặc cơm cố chá phíau thông qua tài khoan chính khoan.
Đại diện át greebang cho biết, việc phát hành trái phíau nhằm bộ xung 1 bún chung và dài hành,
phục uộng hoạt động kinh dành của ngân hàng.
Một bún sẽ được át greebang cơn đối bình bướng đáp ứng tầy đủ như cầu vốn phục bụng
phát triển sản xuất, kinh dành và thác sự an chọn điểm Quốc sà.